مسيره شاقه رحله لجوء بدات من هنا من
سوريا الى السودان لجا الى الخرطوم قبل
سنوات هربا من الحرب لينتهي به الحال في
مواجهه حرب اخرى اما ننصح بالحرب عيسى شاب
سوري استقر به الحال بين اهالي ولايه كسلا
تبعد 700 كم عن معارك الخرطوم لكن قبل
وصوله الى مدينه حلفا عاش قصه نزوح مضطربه
المعارك كانت على مرمى حجر منه قرر العوده
الى سوريا عبر رحلات اجلاء من بورتسودان
لكن ما كان ينتظره اسوا
في الشارع
[موسيقى]
سرقت
المسار اللي معك مئات الالاف يرغبون
بالعوده لكن الطريق الى المعابر ان لم تكن
مدروسه امنيا محفوفه بقطاع الطرق او مفخخه
بتجار حرب تجار باتوا لا ينقلون النازحين
الا بالاف الدولارات ما جعلهم غنيمه
لعمليات نهب لا تصدها هدى غذاء السالم
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات